[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I'm pretty good at Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your questions give you
two views advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John what did the doctor say
that the patient who wanted an
appointment because they had become
invisible what I'm sorry I can't see you
right now
that's terrible I'm sorry that that is
the worst one yet I don't love this bit
but I was willing to accept it until
that one we do this on tour and every
dad joke got a huge a huge round of
applause from the minority of the
audience but those people well Hank I
have a bit of good news for you good
news Robert Muller is ready to deliver
key findings in his Trump probe say
sources after the midnight elections
tops still have well that's good news
oh god this is what the good news
segment is supposed to be for John it's
funny I had forgotten about the Mueller
probe Muller probe whatever it's called
I'd forgotten about it it's just it's
too many other things happening one of
the great narratives of 2017 and 2018
life is that nobody knows how to
pronounce Robert Miller's last name and
this person who may or may not end up
playing a pretty significant role in
American history has an unpronounceable
last name he's like the guy who
discovered Halley's Comet or who
discovered that Halley's Comet was a
repeating comment nobody knows how to
say his name which is why lots of people
call Halley's comet Halley's Comet it's
true it's true except that I feel like
we could just ask Robert and we yell
Mueller no we can't unfortunately he
never responds to press enquiries is
like the JD Salinger of independent
investigators
though he's introduced himself to people
hi I'm Robert Malley our it that reminds
me that since I do know James Comey I
could perhaps use my connection to ask
James Comey out Robert Muller pronounces
his last name I I have in are you on
email basis with James Comey I thought
you were about to say are you on email
and I was gonna be like yeah I'm gonna
have abandoned a lot of social media but
I have kept up with the emails on email
job yeah to you to email regularly with
James Comey no no of course not
um I asked that question just so I can
tell you that I do email somewhat
semi-regularly with the governor of my
state now do you really I do and he
responds to me and I'm just like hey I
had this thought I thought that it might
be interesting for you and he's like
yeah I was talking about my dog to my
daughter about that recently well I'm
like I'm just chatting with the gov I
mean I guess that is the benefit of
living in a state with 800 residents man
try it out by the way if you go to
youtube and you search robert muller it
autofills
saying his own name so we're not the
first person we're not the first person
to have this question what does it say
you know there's a bunch of links that
don't include Robert Miller saying is
our name so pretty difficult YouTube
search results okay let's go ahead and
move on to some questions from our
listeners all right this one comes from
Liesl who asks dear Hank and John my
roommate just caught a cold from me as I
am recovering from that cold and I would
like to provide care for her in any way
I can
that's very sweet unfortunately the only
thing I can think to do is cook and I am
NOT a very good cook she does a lot of
the cooking you have a roommate that
does a lot of the cooking that's a
mouthing that's amazing Wow and she is
very good at making soups and I am NOT
do you have any dubious advice for how
to care for a sick roommate guilty and
terrible at cooking Liesl Liesl you
don't have to be good at cooking to be
able to cook soup you need to be good
can opening
yeah it's I mean yeah so so a chicken
noodle soup is so easy so the here's the
main thing that I learned about how to
make a chicken noodle soup John this is
this is an innovation that somebody
should have told me that I had to learn
on my own okay you don't buy raw chicken
you buy a rotisserie chicken and you
take the cooked juicy amazing chicken at
that an expert made and you cut it off
of the chicken and you put that in the
soup and then the chicken is good
everything else is just like the stuff
you put in the soup
it's just boiled noodles and stuff and
like chicken stock and like opening cans
and opening cardboard thingies because
now the materials
yeah that's pretty straightforward Lisl
but I'm gonna make it even a little
easier and recommend that you purchase
canned Campbell's soup you open the cam
no you put it in a bowl you put the bowl
in a microwave you microwave it until
it's an appropriate heat and then you
hand it to your roommate and your
roommate is sick alright they they're
their taste buds are all jacked up they
can't smell anything they're not gonna
know that it's not homemade soup and
they're not gonna care because in this
situation it actually is the thought
that counts because homemade chicken
noodle soup does not make you well any
faster than delicious Campbell's is it
too early to have a sponsor
Kaley's new chicken noodle soup the best
soup that you can buy in a can you just
said that it's not the thought it's the
thought that counts and I just think
that there's more thought that goes into
like you know ripping some flesh off of
a prequel no no no the thought comes
when you tell instacart to bring you Pam
chicken noodle soup as soon as possible
for the lowest delivery fee that they
can achieve I don't know even know what
instacart is all you big city folks and
your services do you guys have burgers
uber not come to Montana yet we do we we
got Eber last year and we also have lyft
and yeah it's great I'm very glad I just
used it just the other day because we
took the bus to the mall and then the
bus stopped
um running while we were in the mall and
we had to take an uber home welcome to
Montana this next question comes from
Katie who writes dear John and Hank
i took a midterm this morning and the
last question was extra credit the
professor posed the following riddle a
man walks past a hotel and laughs why I
was completely stumped google doesn't
seem to have the answer either can
either of you think of anything it's
driving me insane
aye-aye matie Katie I think it's just a
funny hotel oh no I think that it's a
riddle
right it's a riddle about how how
different architecture like so the guy
is an expert in architecture and he
noticed that the hotel was built in the
1990s but attempted to be in an art deco
style but got a lot of the fundamentals
of Art Deco wrong and he thought that
was funny
oh I don't think that's it they're
playing Monopoly he's playing Monopoly
he went past the hotel and he was like
haha I don't have to pay that's weighing
monopoly it's playing Monopoly he's
playing Monopoly I've heard a version of
that of that riddle before one that
makes much more sense the version I've
heard his eyes sighs yeah he pushes a
wheelbarrow passion wheel has to hotel
and laughs and that makes sense that is
a good riddle because it's like oh the
whole thing came together right but
there is no monopoly piece that's a man
walking no no no that is a first off you
need to go back and you need to
criticize the riddle that'll get you
extra credit I am a riddle expert hello
in addition in addition to being very
good at taking your test I am also a
riddle expert and that is that is what
I've been studying it's my side my side
study hustle do people have those that's
a good idea we should have those we
should have their qualities yeah no
they're called minors no so that's yeah
minoring in riddle expertise right this
was bad you did this incorrectly
professor and I judge you it's more like
a man pushes a
that past a hotel and exhales with
relief I don't feel like you laughed
like when you're playing Monopoly and
you don't land on a hotel you're not
like haha you're like well I need a pass
that hotel it's very close to the end of
the game like you roll and it's like oh
god that was that was a an 11 that's
hard to do the math let's see where I'm
gonna end up and then you get one past
the hotel and that's the whole thing but
that makes that turns the game and
you're like no only terrible people
laugh in that situation I think you
laughing not to do a [ __ ] no it's not
like a mr. burns moment where you're
like oh I don't have to pay you off like
you're just you're relieved and dr1 this
awful board game maybe the worst board
game of all time a man walks a dog past
a hotel and then makes the noise of I
can't believe I'm still playing this
game and an era of so many actually good
board games yeah it's like what why is
this happening why did I go to visit my
in-laws and why are we doing this also
the other thing that you're probably
thinking is oh my god I can't believe
I'm playing the Missoula Montana version
of Monopoly where all of the streets are
named after streets in my hometown of
1,100 people oh my god how did my life
come to this that is the noise that
you're making right laughter there are
60,000 people in this town John it's the
big city there's no way that there are
60,000 people in Missoula you guys are
counting the cows dear Hank and John I
have just watched Hanks most recent
Instagram story in which he is showing
quote real-time fall as some fall as
some leaves fall from some trees it was
really weird is like I woke up that
morning and it was just like a cascade
every tree was like I'm done with this
these are terrible
however Natalie says it appears that he
is in a car and I wanted to send him a
snappy the t-rex thing that snapping and
driving is dangerous but then I realized
that it wasn't technically a snapchat to
snappy the t-rex apply to Instagram
stories - or is there another loveable
dinosaur who wants to keep you off of
social media while driving dates and
dinosaurs Natalie Natalie
apologize you're right I should not have
been doing that distracted driving is a
huge cause of injury and death and it is
not just the person who is doing it it
is also the people that they hit with
their cars and even if I'm stopped at a
stoplight I still am in charge of this
very powerful machine and need to be
concentrating on that and so I you are
right and you should send me some kind
of dinosaur obviously not snappy the
t-rex John do you have like so Instagram
II know Graeme is it Graeme if that what
we're gonna go with Instagram is a
terrible name for a platform oh I think
that they've been doing all right it's
true but I think it's despite the name
there are some dinosaurs that start with
a G so like Graeme the gargoyle II
asaurus a pretty cool name for a
dinosaur and correct me if I'm wrong but
don't you call a professional Instagram
user a grammar or do you call them a
Grammy I'm not hard I'm not sure I'm
gonna snap E t-rex
oh I oh I guess that's my first
confusion I thought people who are
professional snapchatters are called
snappies are they not they of course
they are John you were direct well I
think it's great that so many young
people out there are making a living as
Staffies I am not at all freaked out by
this world in which I find myself where
people are professional snappies and
Grammys and grammars and it's great yeah
Kelsey Grammer Kelsey Grammer is a
professional he was the first grammar
he was the first grammar but now there
are thousands of them there's van life
grammars there's grammars who pretend
that they're in romantic relationships
that they're not actually in theirs
oh there's so many different kinds of
grammars out there it's wonderful I love
it I'm not at all freaked out I'm gonna
propose Grammy the Gorgosaurus mmm
Grammy the Gorgosaurus what about Grammy
the Gobi Soros I mean a Gobi Soros is a
pretty good dinosaur but as I recall
though don't go be sore I look like
[ __ ]
and unintimidating whereas a gorgosaur's
is basically like a miniature t-rex yeah
yeah that's a pretty pretty seriously
couldn't looking a little good guy I
don't know how big they are but that I
wouldn't want to mess with one
what about Grammy that Guana long what
about Grammy the guanlong I mean that's
good it's just not as good as gorgosaurs
I already found the best one we just
need to accept it and move on
it's Grammy the Gorgas Saurus your
professional Instagram dinosaur that is
here to remind you that it is not a good
idea to use Instagram stories while you
are driving and arguably not a good idea
to use Instagram stories I'm looking at
how big at Gorgosaurus is and it could
definitely eat my at least my top half
in one bite my only concern is that
isn't Gorgosaurus the exact same as a
Tyrannosaurus Rex are they just very
similar there it is very similar okay
alright Hank we have another question
and it's of great interest to me it's
from Alison she writes dear John and
Hank recently I have found myself
wondering where I should look when I am
talking to someone I know people always
say that you should look into the other
person's eyes but I always feel like
after a few seconds of doing that it's
pretty weird and I have to look away
also I feel that the eyes aren't doing
that much while a person is talking as
compared to the other parts of their
face so my eyes naturally want to drift
to where there is more movement you can
call me al listen he's good it's a it's
a Paul Simon joke yeah I think that this
is an example of a thing that as soon as
you think about it is it is impossible
uh if I'm thinking about where to look
while I'm talking to someone
I immediately cannot tell what they are
saying I have no idea what's happening
and lose it all and I become a bit of
non a nonhuman
basically I lose the ability to
communicate Hank I think that you're
actually pretty good at looking in
appropriate places when you're in
conversations with people it's something
that has always impressed me because I
am really bad at it like I do I really
struggle with eye contact it feels super
weird and intimate to me to engage in
any kind of eye contact like I'm
discussing uh the budget for a home
renovation or something and the way that
I am being looked at and the way that
like social norms are telling me to look
back is to me equivalent to like the way
you look at someone while you are making
your wedding vows like the only time I
have engaged in what I consider like the
only time in my life I have chosen to
engage in the eye contact that society
seems to feel is totally normal is while
I was getting married I don't know I
definitely there was a time in my life
where when I actually had a tutor who
helped me with that because I was not
good at eye contact and and was yeah and
sort of was like this is maybe gonna be
a thing that takes practice for you but
now it's not a thing that that i unless
i'm thinking about it it's not a problem
and i think i do look around I look
around people's faces like when they do
eye tracking studies your your your eyes
spend time on eyes you but like a lot of
time is spent on lips and then there's
also time spent not looking at the face
at all like especially when like
considering a response or thinking of on
your own and and so like they your eyes
do move around I just think that the
like the the when it becomes very hard
is when you're thinking about it at all
and that's that's I think what I what I
have a problem with what in those
moments when I'm like oh what am i what
should I am i doing am i wait uh-oh and
then suddenly I don't even know what's
being said and also lose the ability to
speak yeah Allison I would just say that
you're not alone in this and don't
really worry about where you're looking
it's fun yeah yeah don't try not to
worry about it and try not to think
about it of course it is the hardest
thing in the world to not think about
something especially when your favorite
podcasters are have spent a lot of time
talking about it so we may have done
more harm than good here John probably
so as to be fair we usually do it does
remind me however of a game that my
daughter has been playing recently where
I will be in my little office in our
house working and Alice will open the
door just leaned her head in and then
shout monkey are you thinking about a
monkey
mmm it's her it's her attempt to like
control other people's thoughts I like
it now that's that is all that's what
we're all doing John it's very hard not
to think about a monkey when somebody
screams monkey at you so now we have
made a lot of people think about eye
contact when that is the last thing that
they should be doing okay let's move on
to another question this one comes from
Karina who asks your Hank and John after
war disease solar flares and climate
change have killed us all do you think
aliens will visit earth and ride our
roller coasters I hope they do a thing
with feathers Karina Karina are you a
bird no she's hope she's hope Hank hope
is the thing with feathers that perches
in the soul etc but also birds have
feathers indeed that is I think the
comparison that Emily Dickinson was
attempting to make anyway yeah I hope so
I just wanted to read that question
because it sounds like fun I imagine
that a lot of the rollercoasters won't
make it through but they are built
sturdily like for obvious reasons so
maybe they will I went to an abandoned
theme park outside of Berlin once for a
TV show shoot in which like a German TV
show was making you know a piece about
me in which I was supposed to be the
kind of person who goes to abandoned
theme parks and there were many things
that were extremely weird about this
abandoned theme park and and beautiful
in their way but by far the weirdest
thing I actually made a vlogbrothers
video about this was this ferris wheel
that spun on its own in the wind oh yeah
I remember that and anyway I then later
learned that people get on this ferris
wheel that does not work and has not
worked in decades and then they count on
the wind to blow them all the way around
mm-hmm which to me is way scarier than
like getting on a spaceship and going to
Mars
there is a very good chance that you
will be blown into a place that you are
then stuck there for hours or days or
weeks or the right Wow
what are you thinking did your did cell
phones work was it a cell phone II place
because if it's a cell phones work I
think I'm fine with that
uh first off I don't know if cell phones
worked because you know I'm not gonna
pay ten bucks a day for an international
plan this is in 2008 Hank okay pre-pre
Fault in Our Stars I was a different
person okay secondly it's more depending
upon equipment that has not been
maintained in decades and being like oh
no this will be fine the wind will blow
us in a circle
I don't know so far so good I love the
idea of aliens finding earth-like long
after we're gone and trying to piece
together what the heck we were up to
uh-huh you know like these like if they
see a roller coaster and they're like
were these people trying to be afraid a
roller coaster is a really interesting
example of like an amusement because
most amusements are like digital or
ephemeral or like based in in media like
ruzic and and like even if you're going
to see live music like that's the thing
that only exists in that moment whereas
a roller coaster is a structure of
amusement and and so like it's a it's a
thing that lasts and is there as a like
yeah there's a and like even if it gets
buried in the sands of time like it'll
still be there unless you know that the
whole earth turns to magma so there's
like this this record of like our fun
and here's what fun was like for at
least some of us though to be clear not
all of us but who knows if they would
even know that it is a record of fun
like maybe they would look at it and be
like well that is a skeleton of a weird
creature or look at it and be like wow
they must have had made babies in a
really weird way that's what we always
think it what scientists always think
when they find some weird structure on
an old animal it's like well I guess
that's just sexual
dimorphism then right weird right it's a
sexual selection yeah that's like wow I
guess they needed that for some reason
or they'll think it was like religious
or some kind of ritual thing like we do
with Stonehenge where they'll be like
foof I mean I guess their gods were all
twisty and turny some upside down gods
they had everything and then if they
like refurbish it and like figure it all
out 1:1 science would be like no no no
it was just for being like weird and
like getting loop-de-loop don and
because they liked it and all the other
signs to be like you crazy man that is
not a thing that's what I love about
true-crime podcast they always imagine
these like immensely complicated
theories and conspiracies and then it
turns out that it was just some Yahoo
who's still sitting there in town like
on his front porch the cops come over
and they're like hey did you kill that
person and he's like yeah turns out we
just like to be upside down some hey
exactly yeah sometimes the weirdest
answer is in fact the answer I think
this exertion comes from mod who writes
Dear John and Hank I take the bus to
work every day and I was wondering what
the proper etiquette is when you are
alone at a bus stop and a bus drives by
that you do not want to take should I
look away and act like I'm not there or
should I shake my head at the driver to
tell them I don't want to get in please
help make my commute a little less
awkward at the bus stop I don't want to
stand out Maude
I love the idea that you can just feel
like no don't look at me don't I'm not
here I'm not I won't make eye contact
I've become invisible right like the
ostrich sticking their head in the sand
yeah that's what you got to do Maude
just dig a hole yeah get put your whole
body in the hole and then come out when
your bus is there Maude I think you're
missing the obvious answer here which is
to have a sandwich board that has on one
side you are not my bus and on the other
side you are my bus and so you just turn
your back
back to the bus and show them the you
are not my bus sign when they are not
your bus or that's your shirt
Hank that is so much better you've
solved the problem Maude you're gonna
wear one shirt for the rest of your life
on one side it says you are my bus and
then on the backside it says you are not
my bus and you just turn around when you
see the bus that is not yours and you
watch it drive past you and you'll
probably even get a wave in the rearview
mirror because the driver will be so
delighted and then when it is your bus
you get to stare at the bus as it comes
and wave hello and they'll know because
it's right there on your shirt you are
my bus you are my bus
you are my bus hey I mean yeah you just
I just waved the bus along I'm like
you're not my bus go along that is
actually what I do do and it is super
embarrassing now that I think about it
that like I basic you know the the like
traffic cop move along yes symbol yeah
that's the thing that I do but I do it
often times like with the traffic cop
level of drama I'm like keep it going
keep it going not me don't slow down
don't touch those brakes you need to go
go go I know you got people to pick up
and I am NOT one of them you go you go
you and then the bus driver it is only
just occurred to me that the bus driver
must be like yeah no I got it yeah I I
am a bus driver I understand it took
minimal input for me to understand that
you're not my guy
what for this podcast is brought to you
by John's overabundance of enthusiasm at
only one particular moment of his public
life capital stops today's podcast is
also brought to you by delicious
Campbell's chicken noodle soup it's in a
can it's done it's ready this podcast is
also brought to you by bad riddles bad
riddles all you have to do is that a
wheelbarrow to that thing and also this
podcast is sponsored by Graeme the
Gorgas Soros Graeme the Gorgosaurus just
don't use your phone while you're
driving I'm sorry I appreciate your
apology but the apology that I want is
changed behavior this next question
comes from Cyrus John and Cyrus asks
dear Hank and John recently I went to
friend's house and she started emptying
her dishwasher so I offered to help but
she said that it was fine so I didn't
help her and instead just stood there
awkwardly in the living room and watched
her for a few minutes oh man should I've
helped her anyway when I have people
over is it okay to enlist guests to help
if they offer pumpkins and penguins
Cyrus Oh Cyrus Cyrus I think you missed
a cue yeah you were supposed to leave
when somebody opens their dishwasher and
starts emptying the dishwasher or doing
the dishes unless there is like a firm
commitment like when I'm done with this
we're going to watch the Grammys or
something that's when you have to leave
talk about the Grammy the gorgosaur's
sir yeah no Grammy the Gorgosaurus is
exciting new special on Netflix it's all
about why do we even use Instagram
stories can't we just experience
I'm sorry Hank I I will stop being anti
social media when social media stops
sucking Cyrus I think it was a cue to
leave that's my yes usually when I see
like Africa I'm over at somebody's place
and they start doing chores I'm like
unless unless yes and it in the case
where there is like something else
that's going to happen then if they say
they don't want help
in the dishwasher I assume that they
have a system for that and that is when
I don't just stand there awkwardly I get
my phone out and I look at Instagram
stories Oh God because like that's what
we have phones for that's the whole
point is that in any awkward situation I
can always be like oh I will just look
at my phone that is no that is exactly
what they do Hank they distract you so
that you don't have to feel bored so
that for the rest of your life you can
feel instead of having to feel various
feelings you can just feel distraction
yeah as for whether it's okay to enlist
people to do chores at your house I
totally think it is although it can't be
like just chores like it can't be like
why don't you come over and do the
dishes with me yeah no it has to be like
one thing among several things like why
don't we do the dishes and then walk
the Grammys why am I so interested in
the Grammys I actually I haven't even
seen the Grammys in at least 20 years I
had to think pretty hard to figure out
what the Grammys were right like I all
mixed up the Grammys and the Toni's even
though they're about very different
things I mean I guess yeah they both
involve songs sometimes actually I get I
get mixed up between the Grammys and the
Emmys because they sound very similar
and I'm like what the big difference is
that you have an Emmy yeah you'd think
that I would have some more
understanding of it
and yet all right this next question
comes from Carly who asks you're John
and Hank I have an older brother and we
get along quite well we send each other
memes watch YouTube together we even
occasionally carpool to work when our
schedules line up as much as I love this
I wish there was something we could do
together to bring our sibling bonding
time to the next level Hank and John
have what seems like a great sibling
connection yeah it's all for the show
and spend quality time together by
having a YouTube channel together and a
podcast any advice on some good
activities my brother and I could do
together to bring us closer together
pumpkins and penguins Carly you gotta
make a shelf that's actually not a bad
idea make a shelf together like learn
some basic carpentry together here's
here's the secret and I think you'll
agree with me about this Hank it doesn't
matter what the quest is you just have
to go on a quest together like Hank and
I were not that close when in 2006 we
decided that we were going to do
Brotherhood 2.0 and we are close now
because we went on this quest together
ultimately like the fact that it ended
up becoming a job and led to all kinds
of opportunities we never could have
imagined is wonderful but it worked
because Hank and I accomplished what we
wanted to accomplish which is that we
became closer together like I don't
think it matters if you build a car
together or if you build a shelf
together or if you I don't know why I
can only think of built if you record an
album together that goes on to win a
Grammy I don't think it matters what the
quest is you just go on a quest go on a
road trip hitchhike around the
circumference of Ireland with a
refrigerator
just one that's one of my favorite books
is called round Ireland with the fridge
it's about a person who hitchhikes
around the circumference of Ireland with
a refrigerator it's very funny I think
the trick is that the hard part of this
is trying to find something that is a
shared project that feels valuable and
and it's very hard to to like to just
have the relationship without having and
this is dumb it shouldn't be it's this
is this is irrational and it's not how
it should be but if you can't like
instill the value and believe in like
the like the importance of the thing
that you're doing like we're making
something that's beautiful or that's
functional or we are you know like it it
almost has to be about more than just
the relationship the good news is that
there's lots of valuable things that can
be created and and that value can take
lots of different forms so it has to be
something that you both agree is
valuable and that can be hard to find
sometimes but it's worth searching for
make a show like a shelf shelves have
value what what are those Inc what are
those cars that are also pickup trucks
you live in Montana yeah
well we don't actually have one are the
El Camino you know rebuild an El Camino
together just uh
yeah get a rundown El Camino and then
turn it into a sparkling beautiful El
Camino yeah search the transcripts of
old old space missions to find the best
quotes is something that I've been doing
lately it's really fun oh and then turn
them into an animated youtube series
sure actually that's ours you can't have
that you can't have that idea what that
is our idea and it is really really good
that's really good that's a pretty good
idea Hank you're welcome yeah do
something that won't in any way compete
with any of the things that we do
because we don't leave we can't we can't
have any competition this next question
comes from Kyla who asks dear Hank and
John I was left you're fortunate enough
to buy the last signed copies of turtles
turtles all the way down from my local
bookstore however to this day my mum
still does not believe that John
actually signed the book and says that
there was no way a person could
would sign that many individual books
help me convince her it's real pumpkins
and penguins Kyla I got it I don't want
to like explain this John a few if you
are okay with me taking this one yeah
you can take it I'll probably want to
add something at the end but yeah how
did I do two things John Green likes
repetitive tasks it's yet it's a a form
of therapy for him and that is why he
assigned more folks than maybe anybody
to John Green had not signed each
individual book he signed a pieces of
paper and then they bound those pieces
of paper into the book there is no way
we would tell you that that's how it
worked because it actually lessens the
impact if we were lying about the fact
that he signed them at all so if we're
gonna lie we'd say that he signed each
individual book but that's not practical
and so that's not what he did he signed
it lots of individual pieces and I did
this too and then they put the pieces of
paper into the book and like if we were
gonna lie why would we tell that more
complicated version of the story yeah
I've been thinking about this because
I've been reading Marcos news X book
Bridge of clay which is really really
good it's his first book since the book
thief and obviously a tremendous amount
of work went into it over the last 13
years and you can tell it is a special
book but he signed I think 120 or 130
thousand tip-in sheets which is almost
as many as I signed for The Fault in Our
Stars I think that what interested me
about it and what still kind of interest
me about it is that it is an attempt to
physicalize in some small way this big
thing that as as the thing got bigger
it's some it in some ways felt less
intimate and it felt less like I was
able to tell individual readers how
grateful I was and this was a small way
that I could do that and so it didn't
really feel like work to me also I mean
it isn't work like you spend ten weeks
sitting in your basement watching
Netflix 40 hours a week
it was lovely I couldn't do it while
watching much TV I did listen to a lot
of podcasts but I felt I mean I listened
to all of yeah I listen to all of Moby
oh wow it's perfect yeah I found that
watching TV slowed me down and that was
the one thing that I could not let
happen yeah well but I mean you had to
do it while you were doing all of your
other jobs like you had to do it on the
weekends like I fully like I put in my
calendar six hours a day sit in your
basement signing your name it was lovely
I had a great time oh okay Hank before
we get to the all-important news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon I just want to
read a few responses that we received
this first one from Annie and many other
people who let us know that there are
corn mazes outside of the United States
for instance Annie is in New Zealand
where there is a corn maze in the United
Kingdom they have them but what I found
fascinating is that almost everywhere
outside of the United States seems to
call corn mazes maize mazes which is of
course much better why not do that why
not how how did we lose that opportunity
secondly we have a response from Kelsey
who wrote in on the subject of raisins
to save my great aunt Dorothy which
sounds like a made-up thing but I'm
going to assume that Kelsey's being
honest my great aunt Dorothy says that
raisins should never be added to a baked
good because they shouldn't have to give
their life twice because they died to
become raisins they were grapes and then
they were shriveled and then now they
have to die again getting baked into
some baked good I love it great-aunt
Dorothy I don't need you to explain
yourself I'm Ann yeah I'm in great-aunt
Dorothy I'm never putting a raisin and a
baked good again lastly Hank from Taryn
Taryn wrote in to say I have owned and
competitively shown many horses since I
was seven mini oven mini small a
miniature miniature horses Hank pros
call them mini horses and we are we are
now pros because we mentioned miniature
horses in a podcast and now I've read
400 emails about them I've loved
listening to y'all discover how adorable
they are I definitely agree myself in
fact I keep meaning to write in and
suggest them as a topic for the
anthropocene reviewed because of their
awesomeness but now I'm afraid it'll be
anyway I have now renamed two of my
horses John and Hank
in honor of y'all they're retired and
they ignore me when I say their old
names anyway they're actually brothers
the older one is brown and black and
here is a picture of them I thought
y'all might like to know minis all day
every day
taryn and there I mean teryn this is the
best photograph we'll put it on the
patreon at patreon.com slash dear Hank
and John you don't pay to see it or
anything but it is the best picture of
many horses I've ever seen and I have to
say I prefer I assume that I am the
older horse yeah brown one huh I mean I
look almost exactly like that horse and
you look almost exactly like your yeah I
mean I do look I I was gonna say which
one was me I would definitely be Hank
and I agree and I also feel like Hanks a
little more carefree he's having a bit
more fun
he is hair yeah has a lot going on and
yeah I would say that John I would say
that John's deeper yeah maybe a little
more concerned about every thoughtful
yeah I would say more careful here you
you only attach negative adjectives to
me I would say thoughtful introspective
cautious caring oh okay I would say that
John looks to me the more empathetic
horse yeah okay sure whereas I would say
that Hank looks a little reckless bumpy
and Frank hey looks like he likes to
take all kinds of chances Hank looks
like the con a mini horse who will start
any business whereas John looks like a
mini horse who needs to be convinced
that something is a good idea and go
about it in a careful and systematic way
it looks like that horse maybe started
one too many businesses that's how I
feel about that horse
that looks like a horse that struggles
to get eight hours of sleep every night
whereas my horse I'm good man all right
John well in news from Mars I got a
little bit of an update on opportunity
nobody's giving up yet okay so this has
been a bad bad couple weeks in space
John unrelated to Mars an opportunity we
had a Soyuz mission
that was taken two astronauts up to or
an astronaut a cosmonaut up to the ISS
the rocket failed and they had to
re-enter they were safe but like we
don't know exactly what the problem was
so they did not make it to the space
station which is bad we also had two
malfunctions on Space Telescope's both
Hubble and Chandra which looks like we
are have fixed both of those things but
it's never good when you have
malfunctions and things that you cannot
fix because they're in space and then of
course we have opportunity which has
been very quiet so one thing that that
we actually one of the reasons why we
thought that opportunity might have a
really short mission on Mars and one of
the reasons why this 14 year mission has
been so exceptional and like so long
it's because we thought that that dust
would accumulate on the solar panels and
that would block out the ability of the
rover to get light and it would just
like as soon as the dust accumulated it
would be all over but it turns out that
the Martian dust doesn't stick well to
the solar panels which is great so when
there is a dust storm when a lot of dust
falls it does indeed cover the solar
panels but then later when there's wind
without dust which also happens it blows
all the dust off so the good news is
that there is a like a wind without dust
event on its way and from our
understanding of Martian weather so this
is sort of the last hope that like maybe
opportunity hasn't checked in because
it's covered in dust and it needs to get
its panels blown off and once that
happens there will be enough light to
restart the operating system to restart
the software and recharge the batteries
so this this dust clearing season occurs
in the Nova November to January time
frame and it's helped clean Rovers
panels in the past and so hoping that
that's what's going to happen and maybe
that'll that's sort of like the last
chance that there's there's a problem
that is to do with the dust rather than
a problem to do with the Rover
so you're saying there's a chance I'm
saying there's a chance I love it i how
amazing would it be in a Rovers life
that has already been marked by so many
moments of joy and celebration for
everyone including definitely me to have
written that thing off and boom it comes
back online that's raising it would be
amazing it's probably not gonna happen
but it would be a great story it'd be
like a weird movie like a really weird
movie but it would have a great ending
yeah it just ends with it just ends with
a beep and and then everybody going
bonkers you know like they're in like a
Mission Control somewhere and and it's
just total silence they're just working
and there's like a beep and then
everybody's just like oh my god end of
movie I mean that's that's why that's
why I'm a Hollywood producer Hank the
news from AFC Wimbledon is not great not
great played Portsmouth over the weekend
Portsmouth's one of the best teams in
league one their fan owned which is
great actually they used AFC Wimbledon
as a model for saving their club when
they went bankrupt they were in the
Premier League
they went completely bankrupt they fell
all the way down to Ligue 2 it was a
disaster but they're a really big club I
think they have like 15,000 season
ticket holders they have a big stadium
and they used kind of the Wimbledon
model as many clubs have in England to
figure out how they were going to be
able to hold on to their team and you
know keep keep a Football Club in their
community and so that's great that that
Wimbledon have been helpful to them in
that way it's always good to see clubs
owned by their fans unfortunately
Portsmouth big club big stadium lots of
fans lots of money relative to us and
they beat us they beat us to one I will
say I watched the first half of the game
and I was completely despairing looked
absolutely hopeless and then Neill
hardly did a fascinating thing Hank he
made all three substitutions all at once
at halftime which is very rare I do it
all the time in FIFA but it's very rare
a proper football um very rare and
I will say Wimbledon played much much
better in the second half James Hansen
scored a goal in the 63rd minute to make
it 2-1 we're never able to get back on
level terms but you know by the stats it
was a pretty close game and it actually
made me much more hopeful than any of
our previous games or our last like four
or five games have when we've just
looked clueless and without any ideas
and without any quality to finish off
goals in the final third yeah so in that
sense I feel a little bit better than I
did last week but Wimbledon are still
just one place out of the relegation
zone we've only won three of our first
13 games this season that is not great
so hopefully we will remember this as an
inflection point when you know the young
it was it was two products of AFC
Wimbledon's Academy like of the youth
squad that came into the game and did
really light it up Anthony hardigan
especially who's a central midfielder
with a ton of potential he was great and
I really hope we see more of him in the
future but yeah the news is not good at
the moment but we are only you know ones
fifth of the way into the season so
there's a long way to go well frankly
compared to your previous reports that
sounded like very positive
I feel more positive after this loss
than I felt after previous losses
although that is not that positive well
Hank thank you for Potter with me and
thanks to everybody for listening we're
now off to record our patreon only
podcast this week in Ryan's it is the
worst podcast you could possibly pay for
it's true it's true this podcast is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins it's produced
by rosianna halse rojas and sheridan
Gibson our head of community and
communications is Victoria bon giorno
the music you listening to now and at
the beginning of the podcast is fronts
by the great gunnarolla and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]